لاول مره في تاريخ الاوكرانيين يقام قداس
عيد الميلاد في الخ من ديسمبر كانون الاول
بدل السابع من يناير كانون الثاني مثل
غالبيه المنتمين للطائفه الارثوذكسيه في
العالم خطوه تعكس تكريس الابتعاد عن روسيا
خاصه ان الرئيس الاوكراني فلادمير
زيلينسكي صادق رسميا على نقل موعد
الاحتفالات بعيد
الميلاد نصلي من اجل نهايه الحرب ونصلي من
اجل النصر سنفعل ذلك اليوم ايضا بغض النظر
عن مكان
تواجدنا وبغض النظر عن المكان الذي نحتفل
فيه بعيد الميلاد اليوم جميع الاوكرانيين
معا نحتفل بعيد الميلاد معا في يوم عيد
الميلاد اليوم جميع الاوكرانيين معا نحتفل
بعيد الميلاد معا في نفس التاريخ كعائله
واحده كبيره كامه واحده كدوله واحده
موحده استراحه محارب بالنسبه للجنود
الاوكرانيين الذين تركوا وعائلاتهم من اجل
الدفاع عن بلدهم واحتفلوا بعيد الميلاد
بطريقتهم الخاصه في جبهات القتال هنا في
كوبيانسك في شرق
البلاد عيد الميلاد يذكرك دائما بانك مع
عائلتك بالاضافه الى ذلك فهو تقليد نحتفل
به منذ سنوات عديده وهو بتاكيد لحظه راحه
من الروتين الذي نعيشه
حاليا احتفالات بعيد الميلاد تقام على وقع
الضربات التي استهدفت ليل السبت الاحد وسط
مدينه خرسون في جنوب اوكرانيا اسفرت عن
اربعه قتلى وتسعه جرحى في المقابل اعلنت
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه اعتراض 14 طائره
مسيره من اصل 15 اطلقتها روسيا